we often hear a lot of statements like
carbs make you gain weight skipping
dinner makes you lose weight doesn't
eating fat make you fat well most of
them are misconceptions that are
unfortunately spread around the fitness
world nowadays we hear so much advice
about diet and fitness from everywhere
unfortunately a lot of these are
misconceptions
hello guys and welcome to Med simplified
in this video we're going to talk about
five myths related to Fitness and
Nutrition we'll break them down and
reveal the truth behind them so without
wasting any further time let's get
straight into the video myth number one
the more protein you take the faster
your muscles will grow
this is incorrect while it is true that
our bodies require protein for muscle
growth consuming excessive amounts does
not guarantee better results there is a
limit to how much proteins our bodies
can utilize once that limit is reached
there are no additional benefits to the
protein and it is generally just
excreted out in fact after a certain
point it can actually be harmful for our
body there are several studies that show
increased risk of heart disease kidney
damage liver problems digestive issues
and even weight gain with excessive
protein intake this is because by
consuming extra protein you are also
consuming more calories which can lead
to weight gain also it is important to
remember that we are all different and
therefore all of our protein needs are
also different generally it is
recommended that you consume 0.7 to 1
grams of protein per kilogram of body
weight for optimal muscle growth but
this varies with body composition the
amount of activity you do and your
fitness goals make sure you're consuming
the right amount of protein for your
specific body type and goals rather than
blindly consuming excessive amounts of
protein eating a balanced diet that
includes high quality lean proteins such
as chicken eggs soy yogurt or cottage
cheese is very important but if you're
taking supplements on top of that it's a
good idea to keep a track of how much
total protein you are consuming to avoid
health issues eating a sufficient number
of calories with the right distribution
of macros and micronutrients for your
goals will be far more beneficial to you
rather than mindlessly consuming large
quantities of protein myth number two
supplements are necessary for muscle
growth
while certain supplements can be helpful
they are not essential for building
muscle it is important to have a
well-balanced diet sourced from whole
foods containing necessary nutrients
such as carbs proteins fats
micronutrients and fiber this will
support muscle growth and your overall
health far better than supplements
generally people trying to build muscle
often take protein supplements but while
there are benefits to protein
supplements it is absolutely possible to
meet your daily protein requirements
through a well-balanced diet consisting
of high quality lean proteins this tends
to be sometimes be difficult for people
with dietary restrictions such as people
following a vegan diet in which case
certain supplements may be beneficial
additionally a point that many people
tend to forget is the importance of
micronutrients in their diet consuming
micronutrients from natural sources such
as spinach broccoli almonds or sweet
potatoes is vital to ensure good health
this is because when they are consumed
in natural forms their absorption and
usability are far better as compared to
supplements additionally it provides a
more balanced intake of nutrients when
consumed naturally
regardless it is important to maintain a
healthy lifestyle with sufficient
exercise nutrition hydration as well as
rest and not depend on supplements to
meet all your requirements if you are
unsure of whether this is possible
naturally for you do consult a
nutritionist or Fitness specialist
rather than trying to figure it on your
own myth number three carbs are not so
important for muscle growth the myth
that carbs are not important for muscle
growth is simply not true in fact carbs
are essential for muscle growth and
performance
carbs are the body's main source of
energy they are broken down into glucose
which is the fuel that muscles use to
contract without enough carbs muscles
will not be able to perform at their
best carbs after digestion are converted
to glucose which gets stored in the
muscles as glycogen an energy source
that we can utilize during exercise
glycogen is a form of stored energy that
muscles can use during high intensity
exercise when glycogen stores are low
muscles will fatigue more quickly carbs
also stimulate the relief of a hormone
known as insulin insulin helps in
transporting amino acids which are the
building blocks of protein inside our
muscle cell if you are looking to build
muscle don't be afraid of carbs start
tracking your carb intake and see how it
affects your workouts and Recovery try
adding more complex carbs to your diet
such as whole grains fruits and
vegetables complex carbs are digested
mostly slowly than simple carbs which
helps to keep your blood sugar levels
stable and provides your muscle with a
steady supply of energy they are also a
good source of fiber which can help you
feel full and satisfied after eating
here are some specific tips for adding
complex carbs to your diet choose whole
grains over refined grains whole grains
are a good source of fiber and nutrients
while refined grains have been stripped
of their nutrients eat fruits and
vegetables with every meal fruits and
vegetables are a good source of complex
carbs as well as vitamins minerals and
antioxidants add beans and lentils to
your diet
beans and lentils are a good source of
complex carbs protein as well as fiber
if you need a snack choose a complex
carb snack such as a piece of fruit a
hard-boiled egg or a handful of nuts
myth number four fat should be minimized
in a muscle building diet
is a common Miz that is often
perpetuated by people who are trying to
lose weight but the truth is that fat is
essential for muscle growth fat provides
the body with energy helps to regulate
hormones and protects various organs
when your body is performing regular
activities that consume less energy such
as walking or typing it utilizes fat as
energy when this happens the glycogen
reserves coming from carbs can be saved
for higher intensity workouts that help
you build muscle fats are also necessary
for hormone production including
testosterone which is essential for
muscle growth and Recovery fat also
enhances the absorption of fat soluble
vitamins such as Vitamin A d e and
vitamin K which helps in muscle repair
as well as the immune function fat also
helps with feeling full for longer
periods of time to avoid overeating
which supports your muscle building
goals but we need to be careful because
not all fats are equally good for us
there are mainly three kinds of fats
unsaturated fats which are good for us
and saturated and trans fats both of
which are bad for our health some good
sources of unsaturated fats are olive
oil nuts such as cashews almonds and
walnuts and seeds like flax seeds chia
seeds and sesame seeds chicken fish and
beans are also a good source of
unsaturated fat on the other hand
saturated fats are calorie dense and can
contribute to weight gain and opacity
they can be found in foods like red meat
butter and cheese try to avoid them as
much as possible trans fats disrupt
metabolism reduce muscle mass promote
inflammation and increase the risk of
cardiovascular diseases they can be
found in processed foods such as cookies
crackers and fried foods strictly try to
avoid things myth number five high
protein diets cause kidney damage this
is a topic that has created a lot of
controversy for a long time however
there is no evidence that high protein
diets cause kidney damage in healthy
people
in fact some Studies have shown that
high protein diets can actually be
beneficial for Kidney Health
the myths that high protein diets cause
kidney damage may have originated from
the fact that people with kidney disease
often need to limit their protein intake
however this is because their kidneys
are not able to filter the excess
protein out of their blood to be careful
ensure that you are consuming a
sufficient amount of water to stay
hydrated and also try to avoid
concentrated urine which can create
issues in the kidneys while on a high
protein diet
yet if you are unsure of your current
kidney function please see a specialist
that can guide you in the right
direction in terms of your protein
intake levels so there you have it five
common myths about gym nutrition and the
truth behind them we hope you learned
something new about muscle growth and
nutrition if you have any questions or
want to learn more please feel free to
leave a comment we'll be happy to answer
your questions and provide you with
additional resources if you found this
video helpful I humbly request you to
support our channel on patreon.com
methsimplified thank you so much for
watching and remember to stay curious
and stay healthy